والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين
اما بعد
الدرس الدرس موصول حول هجره النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وقد ذكر
ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
بعض
اوائل من وصل الى المدينه بعد الهجره او
عند الهجره
ووصلوا قبل رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
اول من وصل مصعد بن عمير رضي الله عنه
وبعده عبد الله بن ام مكتوم ارسلهما رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم من اجل تعليم
الناس في المدينه القران
وكان مقرئين
وجاء
الناس من مكه ومن غير مكه
افواجا ومن
اعظم من وصل الى المدينه
وكانوا وصوله امر امرا عظيما عمر ابن
الخطاب رضي الله عنه في عشرين راكبا
والله عز وجل امر بالهجره
وقال سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان ارضي واسعه
فاياياي فاعبدون
ففي هذه الايه وامثال هذه الايه امر الله
سبحانه وتعالى بالمهاجره من المكان الذي
لا يستطاع فيه عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى
على ما شرع الله
كانت الاذيه بالغه في مكه
فامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بالهجره من
مكه
والعلماء اختلفوا
فمنهم من قال الهجره كانت واجبه الى
المدينه
ومنهم من قال بل كانت الهجره واجبه
لاي مكان وانقرب من
مكان الهجره
الى اي مكان يستطاع فيه عباده الله واظهار
شعائر الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولا شك ان هذا كان
امرا
حاصلا لان كثير من الصحابه كثير من
المسلمين
هاجروا ولم يهاجروا الى المدينه
وكانوا في اقوامهم
وهذا واضح في مثل عامل وفود جاء الناس
الى رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
يبايعونه ويتعلمون منه الشيء والشيئين
والمساله والمسالتين يتعلمون الصلاه
يتعلمون الزكاه ثم يعودون الى اقوامهم
ويعلمونهم
ولم يفرض عليهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان يهاجروا
وانما كانت الهجره واجبه من مكه
وكانت الهجره واجبه من اي مكان لا يقدر
فيه المسلم على اظهار دينه
ان اظهر دينه فانه في خطر سواء كان ذلك من
ناحيه المال من ناحيه
الاهل من ناحيه
الدماء وما شابه ذلك
ولم يهاجر جميع
من امن بالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من مكه
بل
بعضهم لم يستطع الهجره
والله عز وجل
عفا عنهم
وقال الا المستضعفين من الرجال والنساء
والولدان لا يستطيعون حيله ولا يهتدون
سبيلا فاولئك عسى الله ان يعفو عنهم
ولكن كان في مكه
بعض من استطاع ان يهاجر لكنه اثر البقاء
في مكه
وكانت هذه معصيه
وان جروا
وراء المشركين والزموا من قبلهم على
الخروج في صفوف الكفار يقاتلون رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه
وقتلوا هنالك في مثل غزوه بدر وفي غيرها
من الغزوات
ووجد الصحابه
في انفسهم حرجا من
قتل هؤلاء وقالوا قتلنا اخواننا
فانزل الله سبحانه وتعالى ان الذين توفاهم
الملائكه ظالم انفسهم قالوا فيما كنتم
قالوا كنا مستضعفين في الارض
قالوا الم تكن ارض الله واسعه فتهاجر فيها
فاولئك ماواهم جهنم وساءت مصيره
ثم بعض الصحابه
من كان مريضا من كان فقيرا من كان اسيرا
من كان رقيقا مملوك لا يستطيع الخروج
هؤلاء عفا الله سبحانه وتعالى عنهم
وجعل الله سبحانه وتعالى الوعيد الشديد
لمن استطاع الهجره فلم يهاجر
والذي هاجر
كان من اعظم اهل الاسلام ترك اهله ودياره
وترك بلده وارضه وسماءه من اجل ان يكون
مهاجرا الى الله ورسوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
ويقول الله سبحانه وتعالى في امثال هؤلاء
ومن يهاجر في سبيل الله يجد في الارض
مراغما كثيرا وسعه
ومن يخرج من بيته مهاجرا الى الله ورسوله
ثم يدركه الموت فقد وقع اجره على الله
وكان الله غفورا رحيما
وقال الله سبحانه وتعالى
امثال هذا في بعض من
هاجر وادركه الموت في الطريق او قوتل فقتل
في طريقه
منهم مثلا ضمره
ابن جندب رضي الله عنه
كان رجلا كبيرا طاعنا في السن
وكان مريضا بعض الروايات تفيد انه كان
مريضا
ولما سمع
ما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى في من الوعيد
في المتخلفين عن الهجره
وكان ذا مال
امر اولاده ان يحملوا
فحملوه
وابتدا هجرته وكان شيخا كبيرا
وادركته الوفاه
بالتنعيم
فانزل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ومن يهاجر في سبيل الله يجد في الارض
مراغما كثيرا وسعا ومن يخرج من بيته
مهاجرا الى الله ورسوله ثم يدركه الموت
فقد وقع اجره على الله كان الله غفورا
رحيما
ومما يذكر عنه انه
حينما
كان ينازع وعلم انه لن يصل الى رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اخذ يضع كفه اليمنى في اليسرى ويقول اللهم
هذه بيعتي
اليك
ويضرب اخرى ويقول اللهم هذه بيعه لرسولك
فانزل الله سبحانه وتعالى فيه هذه الايه
وبعضهم خرج
واسر بعد ذلك
يذكر ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما قال كان قوم
من اهل مكه اسلموا
وكانوا يستخفون بالاسلام
فاخرجهم المشركون يوم بدر معهم
فاصيب بعضهم
فقال المسلمون يعني الصحابه الذين مع
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان اصحابنا المسلمين
او كان اصحابنا مسلمين
واكرهوا فاستغفر لهم
فنزلت ان الذين توفاهم الملائكه ظالم
انفسهم قالوا فيما كنتم قالوا كنا
مستضعفين في الارض
قالوا الم تكن ارض الله واسعه فتهاجر فيها
فاولئك ماواهم جهنم وساءت مصيرا نسال الله
تعالى العافيه
قال ابن عباس
فكتب الى من بقي بمكه من المسلمين بهذه
الايه يعني الايات كانت تنزل
والمسلمون يرسلون الرسل ويرسلون
الكتابات الى اخوانهم في مكه يخبرونهم
باخر ما نزل من القران
وبجديده
قال فكتب الى من بقي بمكه من المسلمين
بهذه الايه لا عذر لهم قال فخرجوا
فلحقهم المشركون
فاعطوهم التقيه
يعني
رجعوا معهم وقالوا ان رجعتم
الى ديننا فاننا
نعفو عنكم وهكذا فانزل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ومن الناس من يقول امنا بالله فاذا اوذي
في الله جعل فتنه الناس كعذاب الله
ولا ان جاء نصر من ربك لا يقولن انا كنا
معكم
اوليس الله باعلم بما في صدور العالمين
فكتب المسلمون اليهم بذلك
فخرجوا
وايسوا من كل خير ثم نزلت فيهم ثم ان ربك
للذين هاجروا من بعد ما فتنوا ثم جاهدوا
وصبروا ان ربك من بعدها لغفور رحيم
وصل الصحابه
الى المدينه
من استطاع منهم الهجره وكان السفر في ذاك
الزمن يعني قطعه من العذاب هكذا وصف النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم السفر
فمات من مات في الطريق وقتل من قتل في
الطريق ومرض من مرض في الطريق والله عز
وجل
وعدهم باتمام اعمالهم وان لم تتم في هذه
الارض كيف يعني هذا الكلام
الانسان يخرج مهاجرا
وقصده ونيته ان يصل الى
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فياتي قدر الله فيحول دون ذلك القصد
والله عز وجل يكتب له ما اراد وقصد وسعى
وراءه وان لم
يتم بقدر الله
فهؤلاء الذين توفاهم الله في الطريق او
قتلوا او ما شابه ذلك بجوز بعضهم حتى يضيع
في الطريق
والله عز وجل اعتبرهم مهاجرين ولهم هذا
الاجر الله عز وجل يقول انا نحن نكتب ما
قدموا واثارهم هذه الاثار يعني اثر
اعمالهم لهم في ذلك الاجر
وكذلك ما
ارادوا وقصدوه فلا هم هذا الاجر
فهذا
اعتبره العلماء قاعده عامه
ذلك ان الانسان اذا شرع في عمل
ولم يستطع اتمامه فله اجر المتم على حسب
نيته
ومن ذلك ما جاء في الذين يخرجون
مجاهدين فمنهم من يجهز نفسه ويريد الخروج
مع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ثم يمرض ما
يستطيع
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخبر الصحابه
وقال ان اقواما
في المدينه
حبسهم المرض
ما نزلتم منزلا ولا قطعتم شعبا الا وهم
معكم
حبسهم المرض حبسهم العذر فهؤلاء لهم اجر
من خرج
ولهم ما ارادوا ورموه وهذا من فضل الله
سبحانه وتعالى انه يتمم لنا اعمالنا
سبحانه وتعالى
ومن اجل ذلك الانسان الذي له عاده عاده
عباده
فانه اذا مرض او سافر كتب له اجره تماما
جاء في حديث ابي موسى الاشعري ان النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم قال ان العبد اذا مرض
او سافر كتب له ما كان يعمل صحيحا مقيما
فلو كان صحيحا او كان مقيما فهذه الحسنات
او هذه العبادات التي اعتادها فان الله
تعالى يكتبها له ومن هذا الذي
يدركه الكبر
فمثلا انسان
طيله حياته
يصوم اثنين وخميس يصوم اثنين وخميس وهيك
هذه عادته
ثم يمرض
يمرض عشرين ثلاثين اربعين سنه وما يستطيع
ان يصوم مكتوب له هذه العاده من العباده
وكانه صام الاثنين والخميس تماما
كذلك الذي يطعن في السن
يقوم الليل مثلا ثم بعد ذلك
يكبر في السن ما يستطيع ان يقوم كما كان
او ما شابه ذلك فالله عز وجل يكتب له ما
كان يعمل في شبابه
وهلم جره
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وصل الى المدينه
واول ما شرع فيه صلى الله عليه وسلم تاسيس
المسجد
اول ما وصل اسس مسجد قباء
وكان مسجدا عظيما مفضلا
وحث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم على زيارته
الى يوم القيامه
وكان يزور مسجد قباء كل اسبوع عليه الصلاه
والسلام
يقول المؤلف كان اول ما قام به الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم بالمدينه بناء المسجد
وذلك لتظهر فيه شعائر الاسلام التي طالما
حربت
ولتقام فيه الصلوات التي تربط المراه برب
العالمين وتنقي القلب من ادرار الارض
وادناس الحياه الدنيا
روى الامام البخاري بسنده ان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم دخل المدينه راكبا
راحلته
فصار يمشي معه الناس حتى بركت عند مسجد
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بالمدينه
يعني عند المكان الذي بني فيه المسجد
وهو يصلي فيه يومئذ الرجال من المسلمين
وكان مربدا المربد هو المكان الذي يجففون
فيه التمر
ياخذوا التمر من على الشجر يضعونه في هذا
المربد ومكان عاده يكون عالي او
ويجعلون حوله
الحائط من اجل الحيوانات ما تدخل ويجففون
فيه التمر
وهذا المربد
كان
ملكا غلامين يتيمين
اسمهما سهل وسهيل
وكان في
في حجري اسعد ابن زراره رضي الله عنه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لما قام على ناقته
تركها تمشي وتسرح
وكل ما يجي احد من الصحابه يريدوا ان ياخذ
بخطامها يقول له
اتركه فانها مسيره
انها مسخره
اتركوها هذه
مهديه الله عز وجل سيرينا المكان الذي
يريد فيه بناء هذا المسجد العظيم الذي هو
المسجد النبوي
فجاءت هذه الناقه الى هذا المربد
الذي يجفف فيه التمر
وكان هذا المربد لغلامين يتيمين
فبركه
ثم قامت
ومشت ثم عادت الى نفس المكان وبركه مره
اخرى فعلم صلى الله عليه وسلم ان هذا مكان
المسجد
فسال عن الارض
قيل له هذا لساهل وسهيل
غلامين يتيمين
هما في حجر اسعد بن زراره كلهم صحابه
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ابتاع هذه
الارض منهما
قال لهم بعون هذه الارض من اجل ان نؤسس
فيه فيها المسجد
فقال له لا
نبيعك بل نهبه لك
هو هي لك الارض
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم وابا ان ياخذ الا
بالثمن
فابتاع هذه الارض منهما ثم
اتخذ فيه المسجد صلى الله عليه وسلم
جاء في روايه انس بن مالك
قال فكان فيهما اقول كان فيه نخل
وقبور المشركين وخرب
فيه نخل
شبه الحديقه
وفيه قبور للمشركين دفنوا في هذا المربد
وفيه ايضا خرب يعني بيوت خاويه مهجوره
قال فامر رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
بالنخل فقطع
وبقبور المشركين فنبشت
وبالخرب فسويت
القبر
له حرمه
لكن
ثم
بعض الامور الطارئه التي تطرا قد تجعل
نبش القبر او لا من ابقاء القبر هو صلى
الله عليه وسلم استطاع ان يبني هذا المسجد
على هذه القبور ولا يدري بيا احد لكن امر
بنبش هذه القبور
لانه يحرم على الانسان
ان يصلي في مسجد فيه قبر القبر المقابر
والمساجد لا يختلطان في الاسلام
والعلماء اجمعوا على بطلان الصلاه التي
تكون في مسجد فيه ضريح او قبر هذه مساله
انتشرت كثيرا ونشرها كثير من اهل الفساد
واهل البدع
وجعلوا القبور في المساجد والنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم كان من اخر ما قال في حياته قبل
موته بايام لعن الله اليهود والنصارى
اتخذوا قبور انبيائهم مساجد
فبعض الناس قد يستشكل هذه المساله يقول
كيف يعني قبر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وابو بكر وعمر فالمسجد في المدينه وهذا
خطا
هذه القبور الثلاثه ليست في المسجد واذا
نظرت الى هذه القبور
علمت انها لم تكن في المسجد اصلا
يعني النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ذكر ان
الانبياء
يدفنون حيث يتوفون
فهو توفي وين
في حجر عائشه في حجرتها في حجرها
فدفن حيث توفاه الله
وهذه لم تكن في المسجد
وحجرات الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم لم تكن
في المسجد
ثم بعد ذلك دفن ابو بكر بجانبه وعمر
بجانبهما
لكن لما اتسع الاسلام وكثر المسلمون وكثر
الوافدون الى المدينه
فان المسجد
مازال يوسع يوسع يوسع
حتى
ضموا هذه القبور
الى المسجد
لكن هذه القبور هي محويه عن المسجد لا
يستطيع احد ان يتوجه الى هذه القبور وان
يصلي مستحيل
بينها حيطان وبينها كذا حتى شرعا هذه
القبور لا تعتبر في مسجد الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم
والقبور والمساجد ضدان ولا لا يعني الرسول
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
لا تجعلوا بيوتكم قبورا تعرفون هذا الحديث
امر بالصلاه في البيت
فقال لا تجعلوا بيوتكم قبورا اقيموا فيها
الصلاه
يحث على النافله في البيت
فهو يحث على النافله في البيت ويجعل مكان
العباده ضد القبر والمقبره
والمقبره ضد لايش لمكان العباده واضح
الدليل
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
نهى ايما نهي عن اتخاذ القبور مساجد ومما
توفي عليه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو
يقول اللهم لا تجعل قبري عيدا
عيد يعني مكان يعاد اليه في كل عام
اللهم لا تجعل قبري
وثنا يعبد
لان القبور اذا عبدت او عبد عند القبور
فهنا هذه لها حكم الاوثان في الاسلام
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر بهذه
القبور فنبت
ونقلت الى مكان اخر
والعلماء يذكرون ان مساله اتخاذ القبور
مساجد هذه مساله عظيمه
وذكروا ان في بعض فتاويهم اذا كان في مسجد
قبر كيف نعمل
يقولون اذا كان القبر قبل المسجد يهدم
المسجد هكذا فتاويهم واذا كان المسجد قبل
القبر ينبش القبر وهذه مساله اختلف في
العلماء لكن اتفقوا على ان هذا القبر لا
يكون في المسجد
لا يكون هذا القبر في المسجد
لان المساجد والقبور ضد ضدان
يقول فامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بقبور
المشركين فنبشت
وبالخرب فسويت قال فصفوا ان نخل قبله
وجعلوا عبادتيه حجاره
قال فكانوا يرتجزون ورسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم معهم وهم يقولون اللهم لا خير
الا خير الاخره فانصر الانصار والمهاجره
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم شرع في
حفر اساس هذا المسجد بيده الكريمه عليه
الصلاه والسلام
كيف
يرتجزون
لا لا لا لا مش
يرتجس من الرجز وهو الشعر
يرتجزون يعني ينشدون الشعر
وبيت الشعر اللهم لا خير الا خير الاخره
فانصر الانصار والمهاجره
لا لا
يرتجزون يعني وهذه مساله يعني شدد فيها
بعض الناس ولا يدري ان هذه مساله واسعه
يعني الناس مثلا في سفر
الناس مثلا في عمل
ويقوموا ينشدوا شيء مما يسمى مثلا بالنشيد
او ما شابه ذلك شيء لا يشبه الاغاني وانما
بالصوت الحسن ويتغنون بشيء لا باس به ليس
فيه فجور ولا فيه فهذه مساله عاديه وكانت
في عهد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وهذا شيء
طبيعي الناس لابد انهم يتسلوا لابد انهم
ايش يعني يتقوى بمثل هذه الاشياء
قال شرع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم في
العمل مع اصحابه
ضرب اول معول فيه حفر الاساس
الذي كان عمقه ثلاثه اذرع او ثلاثه اذرع
ثم اندفع المسلمون في بناء هذا الاساس
بالحجاره والجدران التي لم تزد عن قامت
الرجل الا قليلا باللبن
الذي يعجن بالتراب ويسوى على شكل احجار
صالحه للبناء
فاتصوروا معي
المسجد الاصلي
وممكن الانسان ياخذ حتى في النت ممكن
الواحد ينظر وفي بعض كتب السيره خاصه كتب
السيره
الحديثه التي مكتوبه في اخر خمسين سنه مئه
سنه
يكون في رسم لاصل المسجد كيف كان
المسجد في
مقدمه المسجد شجره نخل
وجاءوا بالاحجار
وساندوا هذه الجذوع
وجعلوا الحيطان من ايش يعني
الاركان من جذوع النخل ويبنوا حوالين
الاركان لبنات من طين
ياخذوا هذا الطين وياخذوا زيت تراب ناعم
جدا
ويشكلون كل حجر كل لبنه وهذا معنى اللبنه
على اشكال
معينه
ويجففون هذه اللبنات في في الشمس
وبعدين يبنوا فيها البيوت والناس كانوا
يبنوا البيوت من طين لكن ايش المشكله في
الطين كل ما امطرت بده يروح منه شيء مهما
كان صالبا فلذلك يحتاج الى ترميم زائد
واهتمام زائد فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الاركان من جذوع النخل
واللبنات من طين
واكثر المسجد ليس له سقف اكثره
وانما لانه المطر قليل في ذاك الوقت
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر
بالتبريد في الظهر
تعرفون هذا الحديث يعني امر اذا كان الشمس
حاميه كان في شوب شديد تاخير صلاه الظهر
حتى
حتى تبرد الشمس
المسجد ما عليه سقف والمكان المسقوف من
المسجد كان من ايش من ورق النخل صفوه على
بعضه واذا الدنيا بتمطر تمطر عليهم تدخل
في جوا المسجد عشان هيك النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وصف في احاديث كثيرا انه كان يصلي في
المسجد
والطين على جبهته وانفه وعلى كفيه لانه
كان يصلي يسجد فهد طين
ويكون اثر السجود عليه صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما في ضوء في المسجد
والدنيا ليل في ذاك الزمن ما في انوار في
الشارع وكذا
فكان الذي يريد ان يتخلف عن الصلوات
التي تكون بليل
لا يكاد يفطن له
يعني مثلا حديث النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
اشد
صلاتين على المنافقين
العشاء والفجر صح
ايش السبب في هذا السبب الرئيسي في هذا
انه المنافق هو لا يصلي الا اذا راه الناس
صح ولا لا يعني هو لا يؤمن واذا قاموا الى
الصلاه قاموا كسالى
فهو لا يؤمن بالله المنافق الخالص لا يؤمن
بالله هو يصلي من اجل ان يراه الناس كما
قال تعالى واذا لقوا الذين امنوا قالوا
امنا يعني باعمالهم قالوا امنا
واذا خلوا الى شياطينهم قالوا انا معكم
انما نحن مستهزئون
فصلاه الفجر وصلاه العشاء في ظلام دامس
اللي واقف جنبك انت مش عارف مين هو
فالمنافق يتخلف عن الفجر يتخلف عن العشاء
فمن اجل ذلك
جعلت علامه المؤمن انه يحضر هاتين
الصلاتين
بالذات
يقول المؤلف وفي الناحيه الشماليه منه
اقيمت ظله من الجريد على قوائم من جذوع
النخل له شيء من
السقف من جذوع النخل كانت تسمى الصفه
هذه الصفه
يقول المؤلف اما باقي اجزاء المسجد فقد
تركت مكشوفه بلا غطاء يعني بلا
تسقيف فهذه الصفه
كان الذين يفيدون الى رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم مهاجرين ما عندهم مال ما عندهم
شيء يكونوا يبيتون في هذا المكان هؤلاء
سموا باهل الصفه يعني المكان الذي هو
مضلول من المسجد وهذه في الناحيه الشماليه
يقول اما ابواب المسجد فكانت ثلاثه
باب في مؤخرته
من الجهه الجنوبيه
وباب في الجهه الشرقيه كان يدخل منه رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
بايذاء باب بيت عائشه وباب من الجهه
الغربيه يقال له باب الرحمه او باب عاتكه
فهذه الابواب باب له يدخل منه وباب للرجال
وباب للنساء
والناس كانوا يسوون صفوفهم
النساء تبدا في صفوفها طبعا الباب الذي
فيه
اخر المسجد النساء يدخلن من هذا الباب وفي
اول المسجد باب يدخل منه الرجال
فلذلك اول صف من صفوف الرجال
وابعد شيء من اول صف من صفوف النساء يعني
الرجال ياتون قدامهم الحائط الرئيسي الذي
هو في الامام يصفون
والامام امامهم صح النساء العكس
يدخلنا من الباب الخلفي
ويصفون
يصففنا عند الحائط الوراني الخلفي
لذلك يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم خير
صفوف الرجال
اولها وخير صفوف النساء اخرها يعني هذا
ابعد شيء وبعدين كل ما اجى صف الصف الثاني
والصف الثاني للنساء النساء صفوف قدام
الصفوف الاولى والرجال صفوفهم المتاخره
وراء الصفوف المتقدمه ما كان في حاجز او
شيء بين الرجال والنساء
لانه ما كان في
عله او سبب لذلك الحاجز في ذاك الوقت
فالمساجد الصغيره المساجد هكذا تكون قاعه
واحده كبيره النساء بتصف في اخر المسجد
الرجال يصفون فيه اول المسجد
وبعدين النساء تخرج قبل الرجال بعد الصلاه
وكذلك النساء لا يرفعن رؤوسهن من السجود
حتى يستقيم
الرجال قياما امامهن وهذا كله من اجل ماذا
من اجل درء الفتنه
فهذه الابواب احنا مرات بنتصور الباب يعني
باب كبير من حديد ويغلق لا هذه ابواب يعني
فاتحه في الحيط ما في ما في شيء يمنع احد
ومفتوح ليل ونهار
وهذا الباب قد يدخل منه العقارب احيانا قد
تدخل العقارب قد تدخل
البهائم وهكذا
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر باشياء قد
تكون غريبه علينا يعني مثلا اذا راى
الانسان
عقربا او حيه وهو في الصلاه امر النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بقتلها في الصلاه
واحد ممكن يستشكل هذا يقول كيف في عقارب
في لا المسجد ما في سجاد وما في مسجد ومن
الحصى الارض
وهذه الهوى ام تدخل في المسجد فاللي
بيشوفه يقتلها ويقرا شرها عن اخوانه
كذلك الجميع كان يصلي في
النعال ما كان في حدا ياتي ويشلح البوت
ويحط البوت ويجي يصلي لا ما في سجاد في
ذاك الوقت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر
ان من جاء المسجد فليقلب نعليه هكذا في
الحديث
فان راى فيهما
خبثا فليحده في التراب
ينظر الى نعليه من تحت يقلبن عليه اذا في
شيء في النعل يحكه في التراب تخلص منه
وبعدين يدخل المسجد ويصف
ونادر جدا جدا جدا
انه حدا يصلي
حافيا هذا شيء نادر
اصل كانوا يصلوا بالاحذيه وكانوا يصلوا
به وبعض الناس يقول كيف يعني
الله عز وجل يقول لموسى فاخنع فخلعن عليك
انك بالوادي المقدس طوى
بعض الناس قرا هذه الايه ويقول لك لا
الصلاه في البوت محرم لا هو الاصل الصلاه
في البوت
وهذا كان شيئا خاصا بموسى عليه السلام
لذلك الروايات كثيره كثيره كثيره كثيره
في صلاه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم واصحابه
في الاحذيه وفي النعال
صحيح صحيح
فهذه المساله كانت يعني خصيصه بالمسلمين
وكذلك
خصيصه باهل السنه
ولذلك بعض العلماء يذكرون في كتب العقيده
ورسالاتهم في العقيده الماسح على الخفين
والصلاه في الخفين والصلاه في النعال
الخف طبعا شيء من جلد قاسي يقوم بنفسه له
اوصاف معينه ما يعني انا ما عمري شفت خفين
حقيقتين مثل الخفاف اللي كانت في زمن
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم هذه
يقال لها
خفاف موجوده في
الدكان في الدكاكين العربيه الاسلاميه من
جلد الواح جلد ناعم وحلو لو تمشي فيه
شوي بتقطع هذا ليس على شكل
الخفاف التي كانت في وقت النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
الخوف في زمنه كان
من جلد صلب يقوم بنفسه يستطيع الانسان
يسافر فيهما يمشي ليالي وايام
نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين وجزاكم الله خيرا